. So we have completely predictable and yet
blockbuster bombshell news related to this
Russian bounty story.
So yesterday we kind of gave you the initial
outline of this story as the story goes.
We learned a few days ago, thanks to reporting
from The New York Times, that Russia was offering
cash bounties.
It's like a bonus for Taliban connected troops
who killed U.S. or coalition troops in Afghanistan.
And immediately the question was, does Trump
know about this?
Did Trump know about this?
Was Trump aware of this when he was glad handing
with Vladimir Putin, saying Putin should be
part of the G8?
Let's make the G7, the G8 again.
We heard nothing from the White House for
24 hours.
Then we started getting statements that Trump
was never briefed on it.
Trump simply had no idea.
Why wasn't Trump briefed?
It wasn't really clear.
There were claims that it wasn't considered
credible enough to brief Donald Trump.
There were claims that it just Trump doesn't
get briefed about everything that's going
on.
But it was weird because we knew that the
National Security Council had indeed taken
up this issue.
We started hearing from other elected officials
who said, well, I had heard about this issue.
We learned that British intelligence and a
top British politicians were aware of and
discussing this.
So it started to become a little difficult
to believe that Donald Trump had not actually
been briefed.
But they insisted on it.
Kaley McKenny, Donald Trump's press secretary,
when asked about this, said indeed that Donald
Trump was not briefed because the intelligence
was not credible.
I'll say this, that the U.S. receives thousands
of reports a day on intelligence and they're
subject to strict scrutiny while the White
House does not routinely comment on alleged
intelligence or internal deliberations.
The CIA director, NSA national security adviser
and the chief of staff can all confirm.
And neither the president nor the vice president
were briefed on the alleged friendship, Russian
bounty intelligence.
Has he been since briefed since all these
reports came out?
So let me back up and say this, that there
is no consensus within the intelligence community
on these allegations.
And in fact, there are dissenting opinions
from some in the intelligence community with
regards to the veracity of what's being reported
on in the veracity of the underlying allegations
continue to be evaluated.
So, again, it didn't really pass the sniff
test.
We knew it went to the National Security Council.
And now we have multiple sources saying that
Trump knew all along.
Anybody shocked?
The New York Times, The Associated Press,
CNN, all reporting about different sources
who say Trump was briefed, Trump knew.
So let's go through some of the different
claims.
There's a New York Times report which says
that Trump was briefed in February of this
year.
OK, so that would be like four or five months
ago.
And that Trump was briefed about the Russian
bounties in his presidential daily briefing.
Now, the thing about it being in the presidential
daily briefing is that we know that that has
been a challenging text for Donald Trump.
Presidential daily briefings with other presidents
have been 30, 40 pages long and come with
quite a long briefing with intelligence staff.
Donald Trump doesn't read oftentimes as he
has been given the briefings.
He's watching a TV that's in the back of the
room.
The presidential daily briefing was short
and short and shortened all the way to one
page.
One page was too much.
So it was shortened to just a few bullet points
with a picture or two, like a graph or a chart.
And even then, we don't know that Donald Trump
is actually looking at it.
So it seems as though it was at minimum in
the presidential daily briefing.
Whether Trump actually looked at it is a question
mark.
Whether Trump remembers it is another question
Because as we've said before, Donald Trump
and his memory problems, there have been wide
allegations that Trump genuinely doesn't remember
a damn thing.
So that's The New York Times report.
Then we have a CNN report.
CNN has its own sources which say that Donald
Trump was briefed directly about the Russian
bounty story in spring.
So spring could be March, April, May ish.
The New York Times report says certainly February
2020.
The CNN report says it was a little more recent
sometime in spring of 2020.
You then have a third report from the Associated
Press which says that top officials in the
White House were aware of the Russian bounty's
situation early last year in 2019, a full
year earlier than The New York Times and Associate
and CNN are currently reporting.
And then we heard from Democratic Senator
Chris Murphy, who says that the argument that
this was not credible information is is a
wrong it's a bad argument that he saw the
intelligence, that it is clearly not a hoax
and that that would not be a valid reason
for keeping this information from Donald Trump.
So on day one, really, day two, because they
didn't say anything about it for 24 hours
when the White House first said Trump was
never briefed.
We assumed that that was a lie.
The details are now confirming it with New
York Times, CNN and Associated Press sources
all saying the president was indeed briefed.
This sort of reminded me.
You know, Trump has this.
Hear no evil Seno evil sort of mentality.
Trump recently said multiple times I was encouraging
less testing because less testing means we
find fewer cases.
It would be analogous to saying if we cancel
border patrol, we're not going to catch anybody
crossing the border.
Problem solved.
Right.
This is sort of another example of that.
If Trump stops reading reports on terrorism
or he pretends they don't exist or he ignores
them, then it's sort of like the terrorism
isn't going on.
If he doesn't remember or doesn't read or
doesn't pay attention to the Russian bounty
story.
It's sort of like it's not going on.
And of course, the implications are absolutely
insane.
Donald Trump allegedly being aware of the
Russian bounty story, still was publicly arguing
that he wants Vladimir Putin and Russia back
in the G7 to make it the G8. Trump invited
the Taliban to go to Camp David and meet with
him, allegedly after knowing that they were
being paid bounties when they were killing
U.S. or coalition troops.
Trump ended up having to cancel that secret
meeting with the Taliban because things went
haywire and people rightly said, what the
hell are you doing here?
What what exactly is the idea here?
Abruptly getting canceled.
Trump was withholding aid to Ukraine, an ally
aid that would have been used to resist aggression
from Russia after he was briefed that Russia
was offering bounties when Taliban linked
individuals killed the U.S. or coalition forces.
So that none of it is surprising.
The lies are not surprising.
The duplicitous nature of what's being said.
But none of it is surprising.
But I think now we don't want to get stuck
on.
When did Trump know?
And did Trump know from clearly was told.
And he was told a while ago whether he retained
it or not.
That's that's a different question.
Trump now knows it's now been what are we
on day five since this story broke?
What is Trump doing now?
What has Trump done since finding out last
week?
We're hearing very little about that.
And that is arguably as important a story
as when Trump knew and who told him